laufen um die skandieren die haben
häuser die mit fahnen dekorierten wo man
denkt man wäre ein paar jahrzehnte
zurück sie erreichen mit den
demonstrationen als auffangbecken
fungiert die partei die rechte insofern
unterscheidet sie sich von anderen
parteien im rechten spektrum durch eine
größere radikalität durch einen klaren
antisemitismus die dürfen auch nicht
mehr werden und die dürfen auch nicht
akzeptiert werden oder geduldet werden
sondern muss immer der widerspruch er
permanent der widerspruch das ist hier
die emser straße 2 das sind also die
beiden häuser die ich hier
ausschließlich vom nationalsozialismus